the emily's case is what i would call a
classic case of lip overfilling you're
putting your um your faith in
your face basically in the hands of
someone who's supposed to know what
they're doing and they're expected to do
what is best for you and sometimes that
means saying no and i think they didn't
say no to you obviously an mri scan
reveals what's going on under the skin
so here we have a sagittal
cross section of emily's face
and you can see the lip filler is
highlighted literally in white it's not
just in the red part of your lip which
is down here the vermilion but it's also
starting to track up towards your nose
and in the chin or in the lower lip it's
going to go down to your chin how much
do you think is still in there i
wouldn't be surprised if every drop of
filler that she's ever had is still
there i would have got it initially done
probably about five years ago and since
then i've had it done probably about
six times
filler is supposed to last for six to 18
months that's what everyone
believes and and still to this day
believes and you believed it for many
years absolutely so we put them through
the mri scanner
and what we found was really staggering
fillers were lasting way way longer than
6 to 18 months so we had of the initial
10 patients that we scanned pretty much
all of them had fillers lasting for
longer than 2 years
anywhere up to 12 years
couldn't it be argued that that's a good
thing i don't have to go back as
frequently it's still there my face and
lips are still plumped up you know if
you think about it something that's
permanent or semi-permanent
is way more lethal than something that's
temporary and certainly if you were to
follow the old paradigm of that fillers
last six to 18 months you could inject
them ethically every six to 18 months if
they're lasting 10-12 years
it's a completely different ballgame
and an accumulation of filler injections
can be disfiguring
i just had one the other day and she
literally had like this um you know golf
ball
nodule in her cheek the physical
manifestation is part of the issue the
way a patient sees themselves and how
that affects their mental health is
another
the problem comes when you have to
dissolve someone and it's a bit more
wrinkly or be more sunken
it's very poorly accepted so
really you've got to never get to that
point where you're overfilled because
it's it's plays a huge impact on you
psychologically
[Music]
emily had more feel that her lips could
hold but what she didn't know was that
it was spreading elsewhere
has it made you self-conscious yeah it
has
my sister was actually the one that
pointed out because she gets them done
as well and hers
has looked really good you know it's got
that really nice crisp line um yeah that
outlines them and
she was just like oh you're something
very good at all see how thick they are
all the way up to the nose so i
definitely traveled further up i mean
that's a lot thicker than what i'd
expect so this is just a little bit of
local anesthetic and we'll put that just
in the skin here where we go in with a
cannula you know there is a chance that
it gets removed and then you freak out i
know i feel like i'm gonna not know
myself you're not gonna run off and go
get another five mils no i promise i can
promise that
definitely not
[Music]
so i'm just going to aim just above the
lip where the filler is migrated
this stuff naturally spreads around this
dissolving agent it's actually used as a
spreading agent how does this process
work because it looks like
emily's lips are getting bigger the fact
is you're putting stuff in
but and also your body will react to it
yeah but in a day or two that will
shrink quite quickly okay yeah so what
i'm doing here is aiming for the parts
which we saw in the mri that there was
some filler just beneath the lip
it's not easy to watch
a little bit here
it's the very best bit
yeah let's have a look
oh my god i don't want to it's just
temporary but
oh my god
we thought
yeah
oh my gosh
we're into the dissolving like start
like straight away yeah yeah they'll go
in about three hours
if these temporary fillers are actually
more permanent practitioners could be
over prescribing
and patients whose filler has moved
could mistake a lack of definition as
time for a top-up
it's why perhaps we're seeing that field
lip look become more common
[Music]
you